we're celebrating asian american pacific
islander heritage monday joining us
today as a performer from cobb by cirque
du soleil noriko takahashi is amazingly
talented when it comes to baton twirling
and she has a fascinating background and
will share that with us today noriko
thank you so much for being here today
thank you for having me you are a gold
medalist as a result of your talents
yeah but it's a long time ago i don't
care how long ago it was that's amazing
thank you congratulations on that and
you've been with caw now for a long time
yes it's since the beginning so
17 18 years wow
that is fantastic obviously it's
something you enjoy yes i love that show
what do you enjoy most about it
car has story and
i can
explain my
emotion emotion feeling
and
i and also baton touring is
real minor sports but i can show pat on
turning to the
many
people at the one time right by now
there have been hundreds of thousands of
people who have watched you perform yes
you are you play the role of the
archer's daughter is that correct yes
right and
that is uh the difference between kaw
and some of the other cirque shows is
there is a story that is told there's a
beginning middle and end to that story
and it's really beautiful for those of
you who haven't seen it how did you
become a member of the cast
it's long story but make sure
first of all they
asked
anybody for the
making a movie
and then i send a video regiment
photos
and that
production never happened and then
another turning show wanted the button
torah
and do the same thing but never happened
and i just waited and then i got the
email from suck and it says
we
want you to the new show it's very short
email
and
if you are interested you can join us
and oh of course a few false starts and
then it turned out great
your culture is so beautiful and you're
sharing some of that today with what
you're wearing tell us about that
this is called yukata
one of the kimono kimono is a cloth
and we
wear this
especially for the summer because it's
just one layer
and usually the kimono the traditional
um how do you say more formal kimono has
more layers but this is just one layer
so it's good for the summer and we enjoy
wearing this
uh
often we go
we wear this to go to a festival yeah
and enjoy the
feeding and it is yeah
it is absolutely beautiful and and so is
kaw and everything that you do there
noriko thank you so much for being here
today thank you so much really really
appreciate it
performs saturday through wednesday
and that's at seven and nine thirty two
performances at the mgm grand you can
get tickets by going to cirque du
soleil.com